[Musique]
accusé de vouloir démanteler la sécurité
sociale françois fillon sort de son
silence et riposte dans une tribune que
publie le figaro
au lieu de regarder les faits mes
détracteurs me soupçonne de vouloir
privatiser l'assurance maladie et
diminuer les remboursements
c'est évidemment faux est-ce qu'il est
revenu sur ce qu'il annonçait dans son
programme et non mais la serbie
nous couvrons tous les soins mais il a
dit il est de mon âme et même les rues
mais il a dit exactement la même chose
tous les soins par c'est un de mes
retours un premier recul il y en aura
d'autres sans doute voir c'était une
boulette
une bourde général c'était une mauvaise
interprétation de ce que certains
voulaient oui il faut prendre les pieds
dans le tapis mais quoi il tenait mal
ces sujets c'est pas sa part qu'on soit
fillon était le candidat de
l'inflexibilité il est devenu en
quelques heures
on ya de la confusion raison c'est un
peu le piège des primaires les maires et
maires à droite et après la
présidentielle il faut la gagner au
centre françois fillon se rend compte
aujourd'hui qu'il a été élu dans la
primaire de droite que la primaire de
droite c'est pas la france et que
aujourd'hui tout le monde est en train
de réaliser à quel point son programme
est dangereux car il y a un projet caché
qui est à peine caché ses c est celui de
la primaire on va confier de plus en
plus de responsabilités aux organismes
complémentaires et ça c'est inquiétant
quand certains dans cet hémicycle se
situe dans une perspective de des
remboursements des dépenses de santé
mon gouvernement lui asira à la sab le
mans ont renforcé le droit de nos
concitoyens à se faire soigner
oser faire un discours de politique
générale alors qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de temps pour inscrire cette généralité
s'est joué un peu avec les institutions
dites monsieur le premier ministre aura
terminé de lire ses textos pourra
continuer
merci d'un premier ministre qui entend
se servir de ces cinq mois pour essayer
d'aider le futur candidat du parti
socialiste c'était un discours électoral
avant tout bernard cazeneuve sur son
discours de politique générale a obtenu
une large confiance à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que cette confiance
vous vous la lui auriez donné je pense
que dans le contexte actuel et au regard
de la personnalité de la manière dont il
a présenté sa sa feuille de route
je crois que je lui aurais donné la
seule personnalité
même si j'ai eu avec cette personne des
désaccords sur différents sujets la
déchéance de nationalité aux houles
affaire du burkini la seule personnalité
qui alla l'envergure d'un homme d'état
c'est manuel valls venu de nos rangs le
débat a été mis très tôt sur les roms
pour finir sur le burqini c'est à dire
sur des questions identitaires
je n'ai pas peur de l'identité mais j'ai
une identité elle est républicaine
démocratique sociale et laïque l'arrêt
on peut pas me les éloigner a pas de
service
il faut les battre il ya il mettait
météo
[Musique]
i